so what you're looking at right now is
an example of this y equals MX plus B
business you can actually see a planet
there it's big if you see sorry it's
small I can't control the font size now
when you have a look at this it gives
you a straight line that's look this
whole topic is about linear
relationships so there's the straight
line for this particular MX plus B and
you in fact can see what M and B are um
here's M is equal 1
he is B as equal to 0 now do you
remember like I hope you worked out a
little bit of in a way of notes what
what I am at me what do they refer to
okay very good so this M here is
gradient they didn't use G because it
was taken for gravity and then you've
got be down here which is the
y-intercept
okay very good well another way of
saying that is the intercept on the
vertical axis because we know it's not
always called
y like it can be other okay now once you
see and you kind of did a whole bunch of
exercises on these like on paper I want
you to see what happens as we've muck
about with these numbers okay for
instance and you can also see the table
of values over there at the top left so
you can see what the numbers are they
correspond to these dances okay let's
change em equal 1 into M equals to let's
do them ok so if I move that over what
too fast oh yeah okay have all compare
that to the graph you had one second ago
which looked just a little bit different
like that what was the difference how
would you describe what has these really
changed when I went from M equals 1 to M
equals 2 how'd you describe this ok very
good the slope is sort of gone up Manny
would you going to use the same
different ones
yeah very good it's um it's clearly like
if you were thinking at times of a hill
that you're running off across country
this is much steeper
that's what this M equals to indicates
now here's one I put the screen up you
can see what this means the gradient you
know how like how do you calculate
grainy man the formula for this
rise over run right so I want to think
about okay for instance here is here's a
section where there's applied of 0 to 4
units did you see that and the one that
corresponds to that is 2 0 2 0 2 so 4
divided by 2 that's what gives you the
great you move to and you can look at
this over any interval I can draw a big
one let's go to se Kyung if I to this
line here
have a look at the scale on the vertical
axis what's the rise in this case how
far is it going it's gone 8 right I'm
from 4 up to 12
open hey there what is the run it's four
it's going from 2 to 6 and you can see
it because it's a straight line and the
gradient doesn't change right 8 divided
by 4 it's still 2 it's 2 everywhere on
this line
okay so we are gonna get to this wrong
I'll see if we get to this lesson four
on Monday
obviously there are better points to
pick and hotter points to pick right
wait lucky on this particular graph
we've got like a million grid lines
everywhere but if i zoom down through it
which I'm not going to do because of my
couple lines of draw I'm the some of the
grid lines will disappear and when you
have a look at the book somebody's very
hard to tell like it's halfway between
1/3 between it's very difficult agree
and so yes you would pick the most clear
points that you could now let me rub
that off you can see that this idea of
gradient it also matches to our table of
values right the grading of - it means
that unfortunately this is oriented
vertically instead of horizontally but
he's your X values and here are your Y
values and you see what 2 has to do with
these numbers do you see each time from
0 to 2 from 2 to 4 and 4 to 6 what's
happening yeah you're just adding this
number like that of course if I change
the gradient again let's change it to
something ridiculous that would be hard
to read ok let's go to 7 what's the
connection between gradient and the
table of values you're just adding 7
there are every time in fact if I really
want to I could even say well what if
it's not growing what if it was
something that was dropping right so you
can see I mean my graph is is dunkey now
let me make a physical there you go ok
you can see the gradient is which is why
it's dropping like a rock the rise is
negative ok and you can say it see the
same thing that's happening with the
numbers yeah negative 5 negative 5
million 5 million 5 that's the
difference okay so what that gradient
represents is how are things changing
over time right how's your altitude
changing over time well how is the
amount of money
made it's life-changing we've got that
no hunt our heads I'll just put that
back to a sensible value no no now what
happens when we muck about with be on
the graph how would you describe it
like when we change the y-intercept if I
made it say three what difference would
it make to the graph it's gonna move up
isn't it it's gonna have no effect on
the steepness because that has
everything to do with this if I change B
to something like 3 you can see it's
actually a physique we've gone up right
so this is kind of like look that the
differences are still the same there's
still plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 but
your starting point is now different
does that make sense like your intercept
with the y-axis